hello and welcome to this video playing
FM alias or is it the Elias I don't know
a romance a nettle feed a mass of it
okay once seen it or no never okay um
some old Indian Kings in yet we'll see
probably an old Indian yeah the sister
set up that I'm regularly employing
against her the old Indian or maybe can
you take me to their I didn't even look
at this move Wow um maybe you could have
taken it night a for Queen a three I
wasn't sure maybe he could have taken it
um ok so maybe going three him and cover
it like that now we cannot take cause of
94
yeah Ruby one has potentially like a
form
okay let's go let's go here take a
little bit too long here for this age 3
Bishop e3 I my next move we can wow wow
okay I didn't think of such a such an
ambitious move here but yes sir maybe
maybe you can do it looks like it it's a
shame that I didn't take that into
account I could have played age 3 easily
first didn't I didn't think about this
at all okay so i have to be aggressive
now maybe some before chicks chicks and
let this it work he can take you form ah
what did what about what should never
have allowed that just ate through h3
first and he has to return to f6 and all
this was for north and now i'm jeff very
very unnecessary
mmm yeah it looks kind of icky heaven
for him so what now
I need my light need to move that night
this is a it's not a very attractive
square with I need night f.2d to to try
to hold the e4 square he wasn't
attacking be true that's not the reason
for the move but I I needed to be be
ready for this him
so that I can can hold a square check we
should be six I guess
no black it's better here with is a tip
with his activity a bishop only three on
c3 yet it really should be on III yeah
that would be still kind of okay yeah
that's not a happy mood not at all maybe
I should have played before actually
trying to provoke him into taking would
have been interesting
try to play hookey three here if it goes
through gave eight ok this one mm-hmm
yeah it's that has that so much of a big
deal let's let's go there I mean if he
takes on b3 takes on c4 I'm not so
unhappy about that if he trades my
terrible night there against the e6
bishop I just wonder if I'm blundering
stuff you should see for it's not a big
issue if I'm losing this pawn I mean you
can play that it's not terribly better
so but I'm not very much vanduzee porn
okay he took it shooting for the t5
square
light squares are pretty weak
no now I'm getting I'm getting some kind
of activity you cannot move the pawns
and the rooks had to retreat you're
somewhat passive squares okay after this
you might go cuckoo look on the back
rank so I can play some strengthening
moves t5 yeah ultimately why not
ok so I've gotten the pawn back with a
decent position ok but I what I didn't
do it I didn't see that this is
completely completely equal ok maybe I
can win important that actually it's
difficult for him Jim and keep the pawns
time warning ok I can actually switch to
covering this from the side it will be
difficult it'd be difficult anyway
all right let the thought does not lead
to much okay so now i'm getting with the
rook behind the pawn check check oh my
time check yeah unfortunately it's just
a draw check yeah I completely forgot
about the time it was a very bad time
management I probably should win the
endgame if I if I have a little more
time on the clock trying to figure it
out I'm not quite sure not quite sure
but with covering the porn from the side
I should be winning chances at least I
think it and probably wasn't it wasn't
that bad I mean here I should really win
these checks be sick so I came I can go
b6 immediately assess the winner game
maker why not yeah why not any I'm just
covering everything he's not even
getting check it's not even getting the
pawn okay now all of a sudden I saw I
had no time okay was a bad opening fly
here
I mean I was really wondering if you can
take the pawn probably yeah I mean I
cannot trap the Queen it's really not
possible I guess he could have taken the
engine says why this a bit better after
if for but it's still a porn it wants to
play this kind of position and says
white is compensation well really maybe
maybe a little bit but ok some and this
and this might be yeah I know ok 91 was
probably stronger it he I should
definitely not allow this I should start
with this and drive him back and then
play Queens to idea I'm okay I mean
nothing nothing special I don't have an
advantage but allowing this is pretty
awful after that I'm just I'm just
somewhat worse but yeah somehow I was
holding on check check I think it really
helped me that he took the pawn and it
was quite helpful so here I mean if he
just keeps the pressure on Quincy 6 or
Quincy six is good for example and not
take I think this is a much better I the
computer actually agrees with that if
your screen c6 and tries to maybe like
reroute the bishop like has a very clear
advantage and after the capture I have
chances to play on the light squares and
we saw that rather quickly I had decent
play essentially not quite clear why I
me probably I should do that because the
root end can be is better for me and
Chad but yeah I wasn't i didn't i didn't
manage to to win it and change III was
probably better
yeah yeah okay at the end a draw my
absolutely did not forget the type at
all only when I had like seven seconds
left I was like ooh my time okay well
thanks for watching